so
oh
[Music]
for the basic
well you need to be behind him
you need to be facing his direction
and tilt him
tilt him
in
there you go
tilt
behind him look at where he's looking
whoa
behind him
look where he's looking
tilt
behind him
okay what is it basic for nugget is a
basic for phuket too okay so your grip
is not strong you see
make me have to work the grip
don't start letting go and protecting
yourself because it's not protecting
yourself
oh i have to disarm the grip
dad look then you're going to have his
body
i enter to the bot
stay still
his foot and head
establish center connection
so when i do the kazushi
he's going to go from the front
kazushi
to the kazushi
there you go
he's going to keep his center that means
he's going to maintain you got to move
you don't want to move this way you want
to okay
in
his leg is going to go forward
then you're going to fall
don't show your back when you get up
this drill is for him
okay
balance find my find my feet through
what i'm touching
okay so when he grabs and he's pushing
and he
i ground vector
basically
he is feeling my ground vector
okay if in order for me to put his
energy on the ground vector
he can feel the ground vector he can
feel the ground vector okay
so if you push this here he feels the
ground back right you feel the ground
pressure okay
uh
now
push on the hand and feel the ground
vector you feel it okay
push off the hand and feel the problem
here's the ground factor you see that
okay so push on the ground vector good
and lift one of your legs up
and keep pushing on the ground to see
how you took off the groundwork feel the
ground vector lift one of your legs up
and you're gonna see your balance
stabilizes if you see that push into it
there you go okay
and that will happen no matter where i
touch i'm like a rail to you push into
the ground vector
you see
there you go picture that you have your
leg up he's
he's not really balancing he's ground
vectoring himself
okay so
it doesn't change
when i'm here he should feel the ground
vector he's on using the ground vector
well he should feel the ground vector
so as i come around
to take his balance he's going to still
find the ground vector wherever i'm
touching you got it see we went into you
okay
feel my feet
there you go
now he can hang here all day long he's
not really balancing he just looks like
he is okay
oh
what happens is when you get afraid
you go into yourself
okay
and you lose the relationship
a wound he feels he feels the ground
feels the ground kills the ground phil
feels the ground there you go you see
he's not a great acrobatic he's just
vectory okay
that mutual victory
is assaulted
action
when he
balances
just himself don't push to the ground
that's someone not attacking okay
he has to simulate
the ground vector by not disengaging
from them but by using them for his own
wants and needs okay
try it again
okay so uh
when he
if we were going fast
this would be locked out by just her raw
aggression okay but people can counter
things okay and it'll feel
just like the disconnected uk okay uh
so
uh she's she's balancing herself now you
see so you know she she disengaged from
the ground vector because uh engage your
center and watch what happened you see
so
disengage
and then you're just on your own okay so
you'll feel a bunch of yin energy
you see and so you take the yin take
so we'll do that one first
person is coming in and usually it can
happen but someone can counter also
someone can realize oh i stepped
into a whole bunch of and they go
defensive you'll disengage then you'll
go right into it
you understand
you're coming in you'll feel you feel
that her body is locked in the
aggression you'll feel it disengaged
and you come right in when it disengages
so he has the original thing see there
it is right there
okay you see how it times perfectly you
see when her body goes relaxed there's
no gap
with no she disengages
that's not going to work okay
right when you feel the in space you
just follow the hidden space in
okay let's try
okay so again in kihon the prescription
is an assaultive behavior
but the
beginner kid the bad new kid they're
gonna disconnect but it's good to know
what that feels like because good
fighters can disconnect you they can
disengage right or people can find their
cowardice in the midst of their attack
and they disengage it's going to feel
yin energy okay so you should take
advantage of the yin energy okay
so uh
again this one is not really impossible
when the uk is coming in
fast
but we'll you'll feel it she's gonna
take that foot and go underneath the
kazushi
do you see
do the step you always like okay do the
step
so normally there's weight on there
you've seen but the
the disengaged is gonna drop their
center and step
do you see that so you're gonna get this
step over here okay so we're going to
come up under the chin like this
you'll feel that disengage
just follow it up to the chin
and the stripe on the back is to the
master
[Music]
boom there it is right here
right there
but you don't have to do anything but
just follow
the hidden spaces right here boom
and then
okay try
hey
there's no more assaultive energy they
just turn towards it right
so i have that hand i'm just going to
shoot the elbow through
okay so
they're going to turn this hand is here
it just goes through
well the hand that was on the neck
you're not going to turn here are you
you're gonna wait for me to get back
there right okay and they turn towards
you this hand goes up this hand goes
right in here
and when they feel the turn they
disengage everything you see they come
in this way okay so they turn this hand
goes boom right here on this hand and
this hand goes here boom
and you walk through
okay
try it
he's countering this one see
he disconnects the center
are you you're gonna feel the yin coming
in
he basically he's gonna turn into the
elbow he's gonna turn full
and just keep moving
to the new back if he's turning this way
well this is your d angle
oh
you'll feel you'll feel you'll feel how
loose that comes you see so follow it in
instead of sitting here in
and you're trying to get it
just in
okay
let's try it